this is the greatest irony of all after
spending
two years
lambasting Republicans calling us
fascists and Nazis and an existential
threat to our democracy for questioning
in any way the legitimacy of the 2020
election
the Democrats the very top Democrats the
most prominent Democrats in the country
are preemptively
questioning and outright denying
potentially the legitimacy of the 2022
and 2024 elections Hillary take it away
hello indivisibles I'm here to highlight
something that is keeping me up at night
and I know this group really understands
what I'm about to say I know we're all
focused on the 2022 midterm elections
and they are incredibly important
but we also have to look ahead
because you know what our opponents
certainly are
right wing extremists already have a
plan to literally steal the next
presidential election and they're not
making a secret of it
the right wing controlled Supreme Court
may be poised to rule on giving State
legislatures Yes you heard me that
correctly State legislatures the power
to overturn presidential elections
just think if that happens the 2024
presidential election
could be decided not by the popular vote
or even by the anachronistic electoral
college
but by state legislatures
so much there
most obvious
she's saying that the Republicans are
going to steal the election if the
Republicans win it will be because they
stole the election which is what the
Democrats believe and the Democrats
believe this because they believe that
they're on the right side of history and
they believe that democracy is just
synonymous with liberalism so even
though democracy means the will of the
people and sometimes the people vote for
your party and sometimes the people vote
for the other party they they don't view
democracy in that way they they use the
word democracy to really just mean
liberalism and so when liberalism is
rejected at The Ballot Box that is a
knock against democracy even if the
majority of people vote for that and so
she she is already saying as the
Democrats have said as Hillary Clinton
herself has said for many many years
if the Republicans win the election by
definition is illegitimate because the
people are supposed to vote for the
Democrats the people if they
were not being suppressed and not being
misinformed and not having their
Consciousness lowered you know they have
to raise their Consciousness and raise
the awareness they were not operating
under a false consciousness if all those
things
were true
they would vote for the Democrats
they would because that's obviously the
right thing to do
so anytime they don't it has to be
illegitimate by definition she's already
saying that
and then she's going through all the
different ways in which it could be
illegitimate and then the little cherry
on top of the irony sundae is that she
said and could you believe the election
won't be decided potentially by the
popular vote
or even the anachronistic electoral
college
the the Electoral College whatever you
think of it
is not anachronistic
it is it's not out of time the Electoral
College is the way currently today in
the year of Our Lord 2022 and for the
entire history of our country that
presidential elections have been decided
it's not anachronistic it's the law it's
the Constitution it is the very heart of
that particular aspect of our supposedly
sacred democracy that the Democrats are
always talking about
the popular vote has absolutely nothing
to do with the presidential election
therefore it's not how the campaigns are
conducted it's not how it's just not
part of it at all but because
the Democrats sometimes have won the
popular vote but lost the electoral vote
then they just they just go for that so
even in that language even in their
their
absurd elevation of the popular vote
over the actual way the elections are
conducted according to our constitution
even there are denying the legitimacy of
our electoral system after two years
of saying that we are Fascist threats to
the country we're the equivalent of
murderers or the equivalent of
terrorists we need to be completely
sidelined for questioning our electoral
system that's the best they've got
right now head on over to expressvpn.com
michaelenoll's show today in 2020 there
were over a thousand significant online
data breaches in the U.S that left
almost 156 million people's records
exposed that includes sensitive
information related to children now you
would not let your kids walk home from
school without telling them not to talk
to strangers or get into any windowless
Vans right
but you let them go online every day
without a VPN when everything they do is
tracked by advertisers and who knows
what kind of creeps could physically
track them using their IP address to
protect your family's privacy when they
go online you've got to use expressvpn
internet service providers know every
single website you visit
isps can sell this information to ad
companies and Tech Giants who then use
your data to Target you expressvpn
protects your privacy without slowing
your connection no matter how many users
are in your household unlike other vpns
you won't even realize you've got it on
super easy to use
download the app to your phone or your
computer or whatever you're using tap
one button you're protected it's super
easy secure your family's online
activity today by going to
expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show use
my link you get an extra three months
free expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show
expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show
Susan Sarandon
just posted something to social media
comparing her opponents to Hitler Susan
Sarandon is a very far left-wing actress
Susan Sarandon said it didn't start with
the gas Chambers it started with one
party controlling the media one party
controlling the message one party
deciding what is truth one party
censoring speech and silencing
opposition one party dividing citizens
into us and them and calling on their
supporters to harass them started when
good people turn to Blind Eye and let
that happen
now it's interesting when I read that if
I saw someone post that today I would
assume they were talking about the
Democrats
who the Liberals obviously control
the media and the government all the
rest of it and they censor people and
but Susan Sarandon so far left wing I
don't think as much but who knows right
anyway Susan sarain's very left-wing
actress
now Susan Sarandon
will just go about her life normally
nothing will happen as a result of this
post
Gina Carano our friend Gina Carano
lost her job and nearly lost her entire
career
for making pretty much the same post
Gina Carano posted Jews were beaten in
the streets not by Nazi soldiers but by
their neighbors even by children because
history's edited most people re today
don't realize that to get to the point
where Nazi soldiers could easily Round
Up thousands of Jews the government
first made their own neighbors hate them
simply for being Jews how's that any
different from some hating someone for
their political views so it's
virtually the same exact post
and Gina Carano very implausibly was
called an anti-semite you know it seems
like completely the opposite of the sort
of sentiment she was expressing
but it was the same poster Susan
Sarandon so why does Gina Carano who is
a little more right-wing almost lose her
career for this and Susan Sarandon who
is very left-wing nothing happens to her
just a reminder that our rulers they
they don't care about anti-Semitism or
racism or any of the lines that they use
the the libs have exhibited much more
anti-Semitism than anybody on the right
including City members of Congress
including ilhan Omar to use just one
example including Louis Farrakhan
visiting the Congressional Black Caucus
Barack Obama taking a smiling picture
with him Louis Farrakhan calling the
Jews the synagogue of Satan and and many
other lurid things the list goes on and
on and on
much worse than anything any mainstream
person on the right has ever said it
doesn't matter
forget about the racism the racism you
see from the left obviously so much
worse than anything you've ever seen
anywhere in the mainstream right
our rulers don't care about those things
for themselves
are our ruling class
uses those Concepts as an excuse to
destroy people that they already don't
like and have already decided to destroy
they use it because it is convenient to
silence dissenters which is why they're
not going to silence the liberals who
basically go along with their agenda
they're always going to use it to
silence the right Wingers now
unbelievably unbelievably
it seems that I have some critics
I reacted to some woke tick-tockers
nonsense about religion he appears to
have reacted to my reaction and so in a
full sort of Inception
I will be critiquing his critique of my
critique of his nonsense because this of
course is woke Wednesday the rest of the
show continues now you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]